oh so common problem in playing archery
soft is that people don't always call
their hits so having a reliable way I
mean your reliable way to know that you
hit somebody would be rather effective
in a very reliable way would be a camera
in the end of the arrow we are going to
try to mount a GoPro to the end of the
arrow maybe we can hit ren right now
great
[Music]
what's going on put her knees I'm gonna
try that so Kiki whoa
so he says it's an email like a month
ago next shot like shot so this email
like hey we make all these dart guns
like that's cool like could we send you
something like yeah and that's that
sorry they do work and they do work with
our current Nerf dart selection they're
not quite as high-tech it'll be good to
have around for when we need like a
couple extra like single shots and give
it a shot I'll give it an action shot
all right Vitesse like that kind of like
a hammer shot they hold kinda shots but
they're pretty accurate though yeah so
let's get things started here my GoPro
cool let's see if this carves it out at
all
Nick I've been enjoying your time
working on the same Neko Channel
I'm enjoy that where you learned about
vlog filmmaking a lot about painting is
there a pro tip you'd give to people
watching the blog they want to edit
their own cut out 50% more than you know
it's the biggest point feedback I have
for anybody when they ask me to look at
that work is like too long cut good cut
good rule of thumb when editing
something in determining pacing is say
verbally where you're trying to convey
on screen the character stands up and
walks out of the room if the shot takes
longer to do that then it does for you
to say what happens the shots too long
[Music]
little bit yeah keep going what are you
gonna put it there
Coco smart you're not smart I mean smart
if you have more than one matter point
us up on the outside but I don't think
we're gonna get much out of that
oops we have these these little floaties
this will slip over here in a efficient
manner there we have it
GoPro arrow mount it works
I'm feeling the logic October is over
I'm still alive
I have a daughter we shot everything
that we needed to shoot and the company
didn't go under
tears of joy feeling a lot better about
November than it was about October
something that you guys never know is
that footage gets lost every now and
then we don't know how it happens but
when you shoot as much as we do and put
out a new video every other day
sometimes the scene that you shot a few
days ago just kind of disappears and no
one knows where it went one of those
things is this gun right here a fan
actually painted this gun with the
coridor logo incentive and what's cool
is they also like modified it so this is
actually a stronger gun than normal we
wanted to give a cool shout-out to the
guy who made this and send it to us if
you're the one who actually sent this to
us please leave a comment on this video
and we'll be sure to send you something
pretty cool it might just be a Nerf dart
that we signed it might be our entire
range server probably won't be that one
I don't know how well this is going to
fly yet I think you'll be okay
it's gonna be great its first steps here
we go ready three two one
[Music]
the GoPro actually came out just a
little bit on its side and closure right
there here we go hey that's pretty good
I feel like the ultimate test is this
shoot it as high as it can possibly go
and see go up and then arc then come
back down a lot of cars around here then
don't hit the cars okay
Ren's gonna try to catch it if he
doesn't we might break the GoPro so big
stakes here no pressure
take a bite of this GoPro GoPro I hope
you make it back from this journey
you're the first one of your kind to
ever go into space
kiss red oh here we go three two one oh
it's perfect alright ran run run to your
brother run to your brother got a little
scuff on the GoPro otay knows everybody
on the same music panel really
appreciates what you do for us cuz I got
the shooting new a whole bunch
you may now forget me as that is fiying
actually when I was a camp counselor for
five years of my life
we had archery and I was the archery
instructor for one summer so I say that
now but I'm going to be terrible do we
have a do it is this right this is it's
like a solid 40 degree here we go
like almost pretty close
that was the food that was not terrible
as my parents would say to me growing up
I want to be shot at yeah I'll be shot
at oh I should I do i do want to shoot
it remember that I love you I love you
very much my last words are pepperoni
that's what I wanted my tombstone ready
well that was my you know matrix dodge
the bumpers worked it gracefully bounced
down the street thank you guys very much
that was nice of you I felt some of my
fantasies about to see the footage for
the first time 60 frames a second means
it can actually do some slow motion
that's really cool got twist
so I'm manually twisting it the opposite
rate of spins so you'll see the arrow
spinning around the edge of the frame
but the world will stay flat that kind
of creates a loop
yeah it's really true
[Music]
it was a success technically but I would
love to have like a more powerful arrow
on a more powerful bow and shoot a GoPro
even further
[Music]
you